Botnet is the most prevalent
modern-day malware, and
most internet-based cyber attacks
frauds are due to botnets.
When we talk about botnet, actually
we need to understand two aspects.
One is bot, the other one is net.
So let's first talk about bot.
A bot is also called a zombie.
It is essentially a compromised computer
under the control of an attacker.
When a computer is compromised,
typically the bot code or
malware is loaded on a computer and
the bot code is responsible for
communicating with
the attacker's server.
And carries out activities per
the attacker's instruction.
Then a botnet is a network of bots
controlled by an attacker to perform
coordinated malicious activities.
That is, with a network of bots,
the aggregated combination
of power can be very large.
In other words,
the attacker now controls a very
powerful computing platform.
And with such a powerful platform,
the attacker can launch a wide
variety of malicious activities.
And that's why botnets
are now the key platform for
most of the Internet-based attacks and
frauds.